land on his plane has that ever been
done before a helicopter landing on a
plane I don't think that's been done
flying yet you've never [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] cuz the plane Khan no they can they
literally can't no Jack you need to help
us we're making a war record retention
to be contrary he isn't faster than us
lean is a piece of [ __ ] there we go we
go we got it we got it we got it just up
the height down Jack down jack down boy
I can't go much more down yeah this way
gettin don't turn you [ __ ] [ __ ] we're
gonna hit mountains otherwise I've got
eggs here why are we even trying God the
dumbest you are you gonna knock me on it
no no no no no do it to it okay okay
guys are you ready I'm gonna jump out
I'm gonna jump out are you gonna jump
out I'm gonna jump out I'm gonna get
slower Jack go slower go slower stop
calm down jack just wait till we get
like ah ahead of it okay jumps yeah okay
are you ready
okay okay okay right I'm out
Jax Amy we did it we did it guys we did
it we did it I'm not gonna be able to
land at his [ __ ] thing there it goes
yeah do it
now going down oh [ __ ]
where we going to me how the [ __ ] do I
get this mission from Lester chat come
on now how do i how do I make this go
quicker he was in a plane you've been a
flame nice where the source did you get
in plane from those late explode okay
it was amazing nice one Brad you did it
good job oh [ __ ]
you did it you completed it granny what
are you doing get this boy
Oh
how will you pick me up with is too big
I can't pick up oh okay well that's what
she said are you ready for this [ __ ]
sure what all right sumo wrestling and
you have a [ __ ] huge s truck how am I
gonna win this this is the most Alice
but why am I even accepting this I have
a boy toys anyway what yeah thank you
from the northern torches like the edge
captain the Viking this is strong in me
eh
alright when the jack crosses the stream
it goes when Jack right into the hell
I'm not down I'm not down I'm not down
I'm gonna hit down I'm not down
haha [ __ ] idiot
how are your line how are you like how
are you like lettuce a gentleman's [ __ ]
I've seen in my life have you ever had a
little bit of pizza you ever [ __ ]
strengthen us yeah you can shake if you
do with that I like it do it again
please ah I am just [ __ ] everyday I
can't am me I am gonna do it now I would
scar I am Chuck City I eat a dick okay
look 50 good is it little oh oh biggest
[ __ ] thing I did in my laughs I'm
finished high I bet you did finish early
ready no no I'm not gonna die here gray
silly now come on
then I'm young I need to live you're old
and disgusting come on now ha ha ha ha